(whooshing noise)
(squeaking)
- So it's lunchtime in New York City,
and I just heard about this
burger place that sells
one of, if not, the biggest
burger in New York City.
So I figured I'd grab a few friends
and see if we're able to finish it.
- Hey!
What's up?
- So this is Clinton Hall,
and they have a burger
challenge that is huge.
There's fries and a beer,
and you have to finish all of it.
- Wait, I didn't know about
the fries and beer! What?
- I'm really excited about the fries!
- You also have to do it in 25 minutes.
- Ooh.
- I personally do not
care about the 25 minutes.
All I care about is that
I can eat more than you.
- I think I'm gonna win
this, guys, I'm not lying.
- I would be shocked if
she beats either one of us.
- You've seen me eat!
- Why can't you just invite
us to normal lunches?
- Yeah.
(blues-y music)
- I take back everything I said,
all of it.
Everything.
- What?
This is why I didn't make
any bold statements earlier
like this girl here.
- You know you want this.
- Alright, so there are literally,
just burgers on this thing.
- Yeah, yeah. Full on.
- It's three burgers,
three big burgers,
stacked on top of each other.
- Mm. This is like juicy, fatty burgers.
I can feel my arteries just slowly
closing up on me.
- Mine are opening up and
being like, yeah, come on!
(laughing)
- Been waiting all day!
- I just finished the
first one before you guys.
- Oh, okay, wait.
- Do I get a prize?
- So Rob, right now,
is at the winning pace.
Insert shot of the pizza challenge.
- I have such a head start on you.
- You heard it here first.
- Nope.
Now that I'm kind of getting into it
I'm feeling my confidence is coming back.
- You're doing pretty good, though.
- (with mouth full) Hey, nope.
(all laughing)
- Cheater!
- No!
- You know what,
normally I eat over the sink,
or in sweatpants, but
(record skipping noise)
- Do you live in jail?
(all laughing)
- Yes.
- I'm still feelin' good.
I'm starting to slow down.
But the fries are gonna
be difficult, I think.
- Can't really think anymore.
I might start crying.
(laughs)
- Nobody will beat me today.
Sure as hell not this one.
- Just wait, though.
It might be like the
tortoise and the hare.
You're powering through.
- Do you think that?
Do you believe that?
See, she doesn't believe that.
- (with mouth full) Aw,
that's so good, this is it.
- No.
- It's the third burger.
(chewing noises)
(downtrodden music)
- Slowing.
I'm sure some people out there could
probably finish this all
and Christian just might, but
there's a lot of fries here.
(sighs)
- Ooh, I'm hurt. Feelin' it. (laughs)
(downtrodden music)
- So I think we've all maxed out
at where we are.
- Loser again.
- I have fries.
I did a dent in the fries,
though it might not look like it.
- I ate two whole burgers.
- What's this?
- Shh, shh, don't!
He put that there.
Stop!
(laughing)
- What have you hidden under the fries?!
- Nevermind!
- You literally buried it like a cat.
(laughing)
- To the Clinton Hall Challenge,
for getting the better of all of us.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Should we pour one out for the homies?
- No, cheers!
(laughing)
(chewing noises)
- How does video end?
- With me dying in my food.
Goodbye, summer bod.
- Goodbye, yeah, I mean it's,
I'm not gonna be in a bikini.
Not in this BuzzFeed video.
(laughing)
(whooshing noise)
(squeaking)